Donald Trump's lawyers have sent a memo
to special prosecutor Robert Muller that
is literally tyranny if applied in our
country and in the United States when
the word tyranny is used it's almost
always fear mongering from the right
like for example we need guns everywhere
and no gun control because the
government could become tyrannical and
the citizenry would then need guns to
stop the government's tyranny or for
example political correctness run amok
has become a form of government tyranny
even if you take issue with elements of
political correctness as I do common
sense at some point would remind you it
political correctness is not government
tyranny but Donald Trump's lawyers have
sent a memo to Robert Muller that is
indicative of literal tyranny in terms
of the view of the president's power in
the United States and the letter relates
to the president's ability to do
whatever it is that he wants with no
consequences and we've been trying to
figure out what would happen if Trump
forced the Moller investigation to end
or what if Trump fired Moeller or what
if Trump refused to be interviewed by
robert muller did Trump obstruct justice
by firing James Comey did he tamper with
witnesses when he tried to get Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to Unruh cues
himself and the answer according to the
memo written by Trump's lawyers is no to
every single one of those questions
because the president can do anything
with no consequences period full stop
and the New York Times broke this memo
over the weekend and there is this
stunning key paragraph that tells us
most of what we need to know about
Trump's position where Trump's attorneys
say indeed the president not only has
unfettered statutory and constitutional
authority to terminate the FBI director
referring to James Comey he also has
constitutional authority to direct the
Justice Department to open or close an
investigation meaning the Russia
investigation and of course the power to
pardon any person before during or after
an investigation and/or conviction put
simply the Constitution leaves no
question that the president has
exclusive authority over the ultimate
conduct and disposition of all criminal
investigations and over those executive
branch officials responsible for
conducting those investigations the
tyranny we should be afraid of isn't one
where handguns and rifles would be use
to defend ourselves it is this kind of
totally presumed impunity by our leaders
that is the real threat of tyranny and
what this paragraph and the memo in
general are saying is that it doesn't
matter what Trump does or why he does it
because there simply can be no
consequences Trump could take millions
of cash millions of dollars in cash in
public from wealthy people in exchange
for future pardons of crimes maybe they
haven't even committed yet and there
would be nothing to be done and it's
even crazier that as I've told you Trump
can't pardon state crimes Washington DC
is in a state meaning that all criminal
law in Washington DC is effectively
federal law Trump could have his staff
murder political opponents Democratic
senators whoever and then he could end
the investigations into those killings
if there were convictions he could
simply pardon those people because
according to his lawyers
there is simply nothing that the
president cannot do and in addition over
the last few hours Donald Trump himself
went on Twitter and said he has the
absolute right to pardoned himself for
anything period this is tyranny my
friends it's not Obama taking your guns
or canceling elections it's not liberal
professors telling you to be polite to
transgender students it's the president
writing a letter to a special prosecutor
saying you can't do anything because I'm
the president and I can't get in trouble
period and it would be nice if at least
one so-called prominent constitutional
conservative grew a backbone and said no
more no more but they're not doing it
did the president obstruct justice by
firing Comey no not because he didn't
but because he can do whatever he wants
to stop investigations according to his
lawyer and people are talking about a
possible constitutional crisis if molas
Muller says here's a list of crimes we
think Trump should be indicted for and
the Justice Department or Congress say
we're not going to do anything about it
people are saying that could be a
constitutional crisis constitutional
crisis should be now because we have a
president who's taking a position that
he simply cannot get in trouble for
anything but he is literally above the
law that's a constitutional crisis and
from a practical perspective this is a
pretext to fire Moeller with no
consequences this is a pretext to
dictate the end of the investigation
this is a pretext to net
sit down with Robert Muller and this is
not how innocent people behave I don't
know how many times I've said it but I
keep going back to that innocent people
don't behave this way this is the
attitude of tyranny and Trump is
everything that Republicans were
screaming Barack Obama would be and
obviously wasn't and Trump is running
the exact kind of government that the
right says we need weapons to protect
ourselves from except sadly the pistols
and the rifles wouldn't do anything when
this is what's going on the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad